oh and ekv like who is the man to be
teaching BG Kingsley is a confident with
a humble
original individual original individual
original like I just be doing stuff like
I have all my random phases is new
colors up like a colored shirt and I had
words on the back out like yeah you I
feel you looking like that you want to
try something if you want yeah I threw
the scarf a there was two watches but
anybody watching two watches just on the
same because let's go up how alone let
me make sure this is an old TV I was the
first comedian to wear lights on his
shoes on stage the first Gary Owens I
thought you Nick Cannon I saw you light
I was first I love or years ago I love
that that's what pissed him off nothing
else no credit I love the death with
visibility lights on the shoes who watch
it so you're a trendsetter a trendsetter
trance a my head at least that's not in
your hair doesn't you are yeah that's
what you're doing
okay I'm talking about this right here
groaning sexy this is a comedy night
with grown serious I've seen a very many
of these on the ground
oh very listen hey you girls we all take
the fly just say how many you say no
then throw it in the trash don't one in
your purse
don't worry in the back of your car
don't throw it on the ground after you
to look me in the face Sandra was coming
you know what I'm gonna be I got nothing
to do
I think I'm not gonna do fanboy - two
seconds later it is everywhere
do you have it you have a pick one up
and take the person down absolutely
but you know you're betting this
[Music]